retr tour here and we just recently
learned some very important information
for Nintendo switch owners planning to
purchase Hogwarts Legacy there is
something that is going to be required
for you to do in order to play the full
game and not only that today we also got
our very first look at the game actually
running on a Nintendo switch now it was
offscreen and unfortunately I cannot
show you this these videos are getting
claimed by WB they're getting taken down
by WB I mean we only have a week to go
at this point so it's not too much
longer in general I'm going to try and
describe some of the footage that we saw
there but as far as what I'm going to be
able to show on screen I can't show you
any of that stuff for all of you
Nintendo switch owners who are planning
to buy Hogwarts Legacy for the switch or
maybe you've already pre-ordered it
maybe it's on the way there is a very
important piece of information that we
have recently learned and something that
everyone is going to be required to do
so if you look here at the Amazon page
this is something that's been on here
for a while but we only just now realize
what it fully means so right here at the
bottom you can see where it says
download required see back we've now
learned that no this is not not just for
the patch this is a much larger download
that is going to be required for you to
play the full game however you don't
have to have that full download to start
the game so I knew something seemed a
bit off in my last video when I talked
about how Hogwarts Legacy the game file
size and this is right here from the
official Nintendo page says that it is
only 6.8 GB however when you look at the
deluxe version of the game it showed
31.3 gigabytes which just didn't make
sense there was no reason that one of
them should be that much bigger than the
other so fortunately our buddy Chandler
Wood Community manager over at Avalanche
responded and said hey retro happy to
clarify while we work to get this
updated on official sites for both
versions 6.8 GB is the cartridge size
Plus at least a 15 gigabyte download for
the full game language packs add a 1.5
gigabyte download per language so
everyone who is planning to play
Hogwarts Legacy for the switch you need
to get prepared for this 15 GB download
now fast forward to today when we got
the foot footage of this person playing
the game off screen we get a shot of
them in the menu which again
unfortunately I can't show you here but
we do get a shot of them in the menu
where uh a text popup shows up on screen
because they can't download that day one
patch and they can't download this big
update in order to play the full game
yet because it's not officially out but
what the text actually reads is it says
game content has not been fully
installed please visit the Nintendo
eShop to download the latest game
content however he does still have some
replies up where people were asking
questions about the game and this one in
particular right here caught my eye are
you able to play with just physical
media and he says yes but it seems like
it's not containing the entire game and
he gives a little bit more information
on it here no day one patch for some
reason inside the game I get a quote
game content not fully installed close
quote when I try to I get the pre-order
page so can't download the content
however as I pointed out we do see
footage of him in the early areas of the
game so it seems like you'll at least be
able to start the game and play a
portion of the game without that
download however you will not be able to
play the full game unless you do this uh
what was it Chandler said yeah there it
is right here the 15 gab download So for
most people I don't expect that this
will be a problem however for those of
you who maybe have really slow internet
or maybe those of you who don't have
internet access where you're at try to
go ahead and make plans for this for
when you get the game maybe you can go
to a local library or something
libraries usually have really good free
Wi-Fi Starbucks McDonald's somewhere
that you can go and be able to download
this in order to play the full game so
now if I were to try and describe this
footage to you it's not the best footage
of the game it's offscreen footage and
my guess is that's probably why WB
wanted it taken down is because it's not
a true representation of what the game's
going to look like I mean you're looking
at it off screen so the quality is not
going to look as good as if it was a
direct feed of the game that all makes
total sense and at this point I mean we
only have a week to go so we're going to
be seeing it very soon hopefully
there'll be some footage out there of
the game in an official capacity so
people will at least be able to see and
get an idea of what it looks like before
they buy on the switch uh but if not you
guys know we'll try to make sure that we
have some here so you guys can actually
see it as far as what it actually shows
it is the very first mission of the game
and I have to be really careful here not
to spoil things for people who don't
want to know anything who are going in
totally blind they've waited all this
time we don't want to ruin it at this
point however let's just say that after
about the first hour or so of the game
that is really when things start to get
more graphically demanding when you're
going to have more loading and all those
types of things so we don't even get to
see that in this footage but hopefully
we will soon you guys already know keep
it right here for all the latest news
theories and updates on Hogwarts Legacy
as always thank you all so much for
watching and I'll talk to you again soon